hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and Marvel just
released a new awesome trailer for
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and just
like the first teaser that came out a
little while back James Gunn is being
really careful about how much to show us
giving us a lot of hype and humor while
playing the story pretty close to the
chest which is fine whatever being
surprised is cool I guess but for us
nerds who want to know everything about
everything we did a super in-depth
analysis of this trailer going frame by
frame to find some really subtle
possible clues about this guardians of
the galaxy sequel and even though all
these predictions are really just my
best guesses if I'm right they could end
up being spoilers so heads up on that
anyway let's get started the fate of the
universe lies in your shoulders now
whatever you do
so in this first section we see another
angle of the Guardians epic battle with
the ABBA list that's the intergalactic
squid monster thing that we saw only
brief glimpses of in the first trailer
and now we see it in all its full glory
with its mouthful of teeth which kind of
reminds me of the Sarlacc from Return of
the Jedi at least before the remaster or
the mouth of the demagogue in from
stranger things also check out the sonic
boom looking shockwave thing that blasts
out of its mouth as it roars now it
doesn't seem to have any effect other
than blowing Gomorrah back like a wind
but I just love all the work that went
into making this be such a trippy
ridiculous monster that they have to
take down also I love that all the
guardians appear to be wearing jetpacks
here not just star-lord like we saw in
the first teaser but Gamora and rocket
too although it doesn't seem that Drax
is wearing any jetpack I can imagine him
being like no thanks I'm good now the
rumor is that this scene is taking place
in the first part of the movie and this
is the beast that Elizabeth deBakey's
character Aisha who we don't really see
in this trailer has enlisted the
Guardians to take down until things go
very very sour so my prediction is that
something weird about this Apple is
biology or powers is going to be
triggered as the Guardians slay it maybe
having some weird effect on them or
screwing with the universe in some way
that they didn't intend and that that
side effect could be the inciting
incident for the rest of the movie also
quick side note Aisha has this whole
backstory with Adam warlock in the
comics and as I point out in the last
breakdown this dazzling golden
architecture kind of looks like warlocks
universal Church of truth in the DNA run
of the guardians comics and this could
be related to that but in this movie
James gonna said that Aisha is the
Golden High Priestess of a genetically
perfect people called the sovereign so
it sounds like her character is changing
a bit we also get a different angle a
star-lord looking out through this round
portal which I speculated could be deep
inside the forest covered planet maybe
ego the Living Planet that's star-lord
father who's this entire living planet
thing in the comics [ __ ] in the movie
will be played by Kurt Russell maybe in
just some kind of interesting human form
we'll see and now we see more of the
cavern that quill is looking down into
which is filled with Ravager ships and
this fiery glow in the background like a
fire fight has caused the interior this
planet to start to burn and smolder now
we're still not totally clear on what
the guardians have done to piss off the
Ravagers so much other than yondu
possibly turning on them to join the
guardians
we also get this epic shot of Drax
jumping into the a ballistics mal kind
of like Jack Sparrow facing up against
the Kraken it's also looks similar to a
splash page from the annihilation
storyline in the comics which was a
major shift for Jax's character and a
lot of you guys haven't seen how weirdly
different Drax has been acting in the
footage that we've seen and I have a
theory on that that we'll get to later
but for now let's move on don't push
this but because that will set off the
bomb immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what I just said Kandra
no now that's the button it will kill
everyone try again
kunkka mm-hmm okay uh-huh
okay No so here we get this great scene
with rocket and baby Groot or as it's
known to Marvel's toy division how we're
paying for our children's college
education because seriously baby Groot
is freaking adorable that toy is going
to sell itself like this time next year
we're all just going to come home to
find our baby Groot toy and our bb-8 toy
talking to each other and planning how
they're gonna murder us in our sleep and
I really like how these guardians
trailers have just given us longer
unbroken scenes from the movie like
don't get me wrong I love trailers with
montages of half-second shots of
explosions but I'd seen rocket try to
explain the baby Groot not to touch this
button like a parent telling their baby
not to touch a hot stove this gives us
such a better sense of what kind of
movie this will be and it's sense of
humor and how everything will feel I
also like that apparently this is still
Vin Diesel's voice obviously with a
pitch brought way up from his normal
voice which can best be described as
like a junkyard dog burping up gravel in
slow motion
family how he talks all right let's move
on
Showtime a-holes up
okay I love the look of the Marvel
Studios logo flying out at us in these
psychedelic colors and really color or
color grading is a big part of what made
the first guardians movie so great so
compared to some other movies in the MCU
which are criticized for looking a
little gray and flat guardians colors
popped off the screen and the movie
allowed characters to look like they
actually look in the comics like Gamora
gets to be green and not like the gritty
dull grain of the Hulk she's as bright
lime green and everything we see in this
trailer looks like James Gunn is
continuing that playful liberal use of
color then notice how quill says
Showtime a-holes I love the little
callback here back to the trailer for
the first guardians of the galaxy movie
when denarian saw called them the same
thing what a bunch of a-holes also we
see another side of these glowing golden
orbs on a platform where they fight the
Apple is there appeared to be five of
them in total from the wide shot that we
saw earlier now what are these things
well notice how quill is holding some
kind of device here almost like a remote
and I'm thinking that could be connected
to those so my guess is that these are
like portals or wormholes or stargates
or something something that allowed the
appleís to come into this place and
quill open them up so that they could
summon the monster here and take care of
business or they could form some kind of
trap to keep the analyst in place while
they kill it and before I move on we get
another look at this shot of the
Ravagers getting blown to hell by this
blue blast and now it seems like rocket
is triggering some kind of landmine but
by the looks of it this isn't like a
normal chemical explosion like there's
no fire or anything it's more of like a
gravity snare lifting up the Ravagers
within the blast radius up in the air
and suspending them there alright let's
move on
Oh
[Music]
okay so a few interesting things in this
section first off we hear the lyrics of
Fox on the run by sweet now of course
it's just a great song and obviously
volume 2 of quills mixtape is going to
have some amazing jams on it with this
track along with Jay and the Americans
come a little bit closer and Fleetwood
Mac's the chain but I think the songs
meaning is appropriate for the story
because the lyrics are about a guy
trying to keep himself away from a
flashy girl that he knows he could never
settle down with and a lot of the
footage that we've seen from this movie
suggests it's going to be a lot more of
a rom-com between quill and Gamora as he
tries to restrain himself from this very
flashy woman that he knows that he could
never realistically settle down with but
then check out this shot of quill
piloting his ship if this looks familiar
we saw this exact shot in the first
trailer but notice how the lighting and
background have been changed from a
normal blue sky to this space battle so
what's going on here my guess is that
blue sky was just a placeholder that
James Gunn green-screen in there for the
first trailer because basic blue sky
texture doesn't really require any
effects and then this shot in this
trailer seems like a more rendered edit
connecting quill in the cockpit to this
massive swarm of ships chasing him we
also see Gamora
stab her Godslayer sword into the apple
esc' emitting this yellow liquid and I
have some thoughts on this that I'll
come back to but let's move on
so we get a few shots of Drax here first
him on his knees in this forest planet
so the background with this broken tree
trunk is the same background that we saw
in a shot in the last trailer with quill
and Gomorrah and Drax and based on the
smoke and ashes of the shot my guess is
the three of them were chased out of
this planet's surface and they caused
the ship chasing them to crash and now
Drax is celebrating in the wreckage we
also see dranks crazily stabbing what
looks like the inside of the a bolused
remember we saw him jump inside it
earlier and now he's covering himself in
that same yellow blood liquid stuff that
we saw when Gamora stabbed it and again
I'll talk more about this later but I
gotta talk about this amazing shot of
baby Groot on rocket shoulder as they're
in this shooting spree now this
obviously is a direct call back to the
first guardians with rocket on Groot
shoulder and James Gunn said that Groot
won't have retained all of his memories
from that previous form so I'm wondering
if this could be part of Rocket trying
to bring groots memories back reminding
him of all their past adventures also
notice how baby Groot is wearing this
miniature Ravagers uniform and these
screens in the background are the same
screens that we saw in the final shot of
the first teaser also if you look at the
edge of this frame you can see
yondu so my guess is this is part of the
sequence with the three of them in the
Ravagers base when they convince yondu
to join their crew but why is yondu
joining them again we still don't really
know a lot about this story but we do
know from the first film that yondu has
made contact with quills father
ego so my prediction is that they're
going to use yondu to find or contact
ego the Living Planet and before we move
on I love this shot of baby Groot
letting out this war cry as he chases
this Ravager wretch down a catwalk and
uses his branches to lasso his ankles
and toss them off have you looked
closely as he falls he passes a lower
catwalk where rocket and yondu are
walking and remember in the first teaser
we saw rocket and yondu together while
all these Ravagers rained down past them
so it seems like baby Groot is the one
who tossed all these Ravagers off the
earlier platform like they were nothing
and ratchet was just the last man
standing
alright let's move on is anybody
half out there I want to put some paper
over the death button nobody has
anything not a single person has pain
you have an atomic bomb in your bag if
anybody's gonna have tape it's you I
have to do that's a really bad sign so
we get another great moment between
rocket and quill and baby Groot here
continuing the scene that we saw earlier
and that massive space battle behind
quill has a ton of tiny ships making me
think that they could be part of that
same swarm that we saw him evade earlier
but where is this exactly so there's
been a lot of talk about ego the Living
Planet and what exactly he'll look like
whether he'll be an actual planet
surface with a face and a goatee like in
the comics or Kurt Russell in a more
human form and I know this could be a
stretch but look at the shape of the
whole that quill is talking through that
to me kind of looks like an eye hole and
this small cave that they're in could be
the inside of the core of this planet
and that core might be in the shape of a
face that looks a lot like Kurt Russell
now I don't know why they would need an
atomic bomb in that place unless ego
turns out to be some kind of villain
that they need to destroy look guys I
don't know there's so much about this
movie that we don't know yet and as a
fan I love that but as a breaker downer
and predictor of these movie trailers I
just I feel so impotent only in this
context not in other ways I'm good
alright let's move on
okay only one quick thing to point out
here and it's Gamora running on this new
desert looking planet which we haven't
really seen except in this brief shot of
the Milano in the first teaser so if
these two shots are part of the same
scene that would mean the Milano is
firing on Gamora making me think it's
been hijacked or something but also
check out this weird red vegetation on
the cave wall now some people are saying
that outgrowth could mean that this
planet is ego the Living Planet as
opposed to the forest covered one that I
speculated on previously but whatever
this is I'm guessing this is from the
second half of the movie which James
Gunn has been careful not to show us
anything from and I think there's a
reason for that alright let's move into
this last section
you can touch someone I can feel their
feelings you feel yeah yeah I guess yeah
I feel a general unselfish love for just
murder no sexual no no I don't know see
you stole everyone your deepest darkest
secret dude come on I think you're
overreacting alone you must be so
advanced hahaha just maybe just ready so
this final section introduces us to
mantis now mantis shows up a lot in the
comics with the Avengers she actually
has a crazy backstory where she like
mates with the sentient tree plant thing
and she actually briefly left Marvel for
DC with writer Steve Englehart changing
her name to willow but anyway in this
movie her backstory is being changed so
that she has been raised by ego making
her kind of a stepsister to quill and
she's had no interactions with humans
making her super socially awkward and of
course she can sense people's emotions
with her antenna glowing when she reads
people now you may know that mantis has
green skin in the comics but considering
Gamora is green - I can see why they
updated her giving her normal skin and
this green outfit to wear instead now
Drax mocking quill and laughing his ass
off is pretty fun to watch but again
just like the bro-hug in the last teaser
this is not the Drax the destroyer that
we saw in the first movie remember Drax
was cold and humorless and a man of few
words who couldn't understand common
expressions and the events of this movie
are only supposed to take place like
three months after the first movie so
why this sudden character change okay
here's the theory I think that the blood
of the appleís which totally covered
Drax in that earlier shot had this weird
side effect on him to make him more open
and personable remember back in that
bro-hug scene from the first teaser we
see quill wiping something out of his
ear and I think that scene will take
place right after slaughtering the
appleís with all of them like covered in
the yellow goo like Inman and black or
something and I'm predicting that this
stuff will have an especially weird
reaction with Drax's personality that
could turn into a running joke
throughout the movie and yeah I know I
could be totally wrong on this theory
and maybe it's just the shared
experiences from the first film and
three months of listening to quills
mixtapes and becoming his friend have
turned Drax into more of a bro if you've
ever been to a college with a lot of
fraternities you know it only takes most
guys a week to turn into a bro now as I
said this trailer is still leaving out a
ton of things that we know will be in
this movie like Kurt Russell in Aisha
nebula whatever character Sylvester
Stallone is playing and yeah the basic
story and who the villain is but it's
amazing that even without this
information this trailer is still
awesome and we're still very pumped to
see this movie in may okay that's all I
got thanks for watching and let me know
what you think in the comments also make
sure to check out my breakdown to the
first teaser because I covered some
other stuff in there that I didn't get
to in this video please hit like it
subscribe to new rockstars and share
this video with your friends you can
also contribute to us on patreon thanks
so much to all of our current donors
especially our good pal ponies Stark if
you aren't currently a patron we'd love
your support you can also hit me up on
Twitter at ei vas with any thoughts or
theories or predictions you have for
guardians or you can follow the new rock
stars on Twitter at new rockstars for
updates on when our videos are coming
out alright thanks for watching bye